all right hey what's going on it's bill
burr and it's time for the Thursday
afternoon just before Friday Monday
morning podcast and just checking in on
you just chicken checking in on your
over zoom I you know don't have a lot of
guests on this podcast if you're
watching this via zoom I don't know if
you can see my guests yet or if they
have to talk first but we have the
wonderful newly talented 9 extras a
newly talented always talented newly
discovered Aishah alpha hey what's going
on I gotta get this all out who has a
new album called all the parts I was
there the night she recorded it and as
of tomorrow May 8th 2020 whenever you're
watching this
you can get it at iTunes Spotify all the
places that have stuff like that so
finally how many weeks into the pandemic
we are finally get you on the podcast
what's going on you know just trying to
hang in there I know
laughs that turns into a chronically
I've got a little one at home right yeah
I've got a little kid he's 10 months so
he's he's loving this he's like oh dad's
home to now this is Disneyland right now
for him how would you handle in it I was
kind of it's fine it's the same old same
old it was kind of nice too honestly was
kind of nice to have a break from going
out at night because I was just so tired
all the time because their kid wasn't
sleeping and I'm with Mall day and then
I would go out to like 1:00 in the
morning but now I'm like I'm over that
you know I'm like okay like let's go I
want to go out there's a part of me that
doesn't get to come out when I'm just
talking to my husband all the time and
talking to my kid like I need to go out
and have that interaction with people
yeah you gotta be the you gotta be the
mom I do that well this is think my
daughter knows like unfortunately knows
a lot of the bad words because she lives
with me she'll just say dad dad don't
say that or she none of the big things
that is she goes don't scream like that
I can't computer I go all right you're
right buddy you're right
literally she's three years old and
she's are it like surpassed me she's
like more like emotional quotient or
whatever it's good to meet that dad that
it's gonna be okay
you find that and then I just laugh
going you're right you're right
alright so well my kid now I'm talking
it so easy so far no bad words or
anything but he's hearing a lot of them
so I'm sure that's coming well here's my
question I've been asking all stand-up
comedians when whenever this comes back
and they have you know 19 people spread
out over 4,000 seats however they're
gonna do it can you remember your act
cuz I I don't know that I can well I
mean I can remember everything on my
album because I've been listening to it
incessantly to get all the edits and all
that stuff in the clips done so I'll be
able to do this in my sleep as long as
it's any joke that was on my album you
know but new jokes I mean there's been
stuff that I've been thinking about and
for me I don't really write things down
I just like think about it and I go on
stage and I audiotape it so I can get a
sense of if it was funny to me or not
and now I've been doing these zoom shows
and I feel like I'm just like ranting
into the universe and you're finished
and then ever there's nothing and so I'm
like I don't know how this feels it's
it's gonna be interesting to go back and
try out new stuff and I'm like all this
is this is the best thing I've ever
written and then just crickets you know
I want to be down there the first night
the score opens up or something I just
want to watch all of us rusty comics
it's gonna be going up there and then
the crowds gonna be like like a mini
series documentary I'm just like the
failure failure feeling we're all gonna
get when we come out of this and I think
everybody bumps down if you were
headlining in the middle of your middle
and that's it yeah well at some point
people listening because both of us have
young ones and gotta be there for him I
was gonna do a little run of dates out
here San Diego hopefully Bakersfield and
all that and I was gonna bring yourself
and hopefully bartnik if he's around so
I'm hoping that that's going to happen
yeah great so anyways I was saying
before that I was there the night at
dynasty typewriter when you taped your
hour and everything and that was the
first time you did an hour right
reported one yeah like I had I'd
previously done one a long time ago that
was
I mean not great but it was like I was
like god I'm moving from my hometown
I've got it like you know do something
and we had this whole thing and then the
audio got screwed up and the files were
corrupt and it just like doesn't exist
anymore so like the one piece that I had
it was like so excited about that's why
when I did this like I had prayed I had
planned to do this album in April and I
was still pregnant in Toronto and then I
got this booking that made they said you
have to be free for the next two months
got to cancel everything TV thing so I
did I was like this is so exciting you
know and then of course that thing fell
through and I'd already cancelled my
album so I was like you got to be
kidding me
so when I met with all things comedy and
Mike I was like really pregnant I was
like look I mean I need to make this
happen like I'm coming I need this to
happen now
yeah and he was like I kind of laugh I'm
like you know I'm I'm in the sense of
like comedy in the world here like I'm a
nobody and I like walked in there real
pregnant I think he was just like scared
of an angry pregnant lady he's like sure
sure sure we'll do this will do this
look pretty so whatever you need
whatever you want but it worked out
nicely and it was good cuz awesome so
it's like the first time I've actually
done a whole sort of like real
headlining full-on just like my story
that I'm super proud of cuz the last one
I think it's almost a blessing in
disguise that it didn't come out because
there was some good stuff but there was
some bad stuff but this is like my first
thing to put out into the world that I'm
like I love it from top to bottom and
it's great well I gotta tell you what I
was blown away was you weren't even
remotely nervous if you were like oh I
was so nervous oh my gosh no I was like
I was like you know one of the reasons I
wore that shirt in particular is because
you can't tell how much I'm sweating in
it because I was like like pit stains
from like up here to my waist probably
by the time it was like even starting oh
it was funny about that is I you didn't
look nervous at all to me so I invented
this whole thing in my head I'm like
that's right she played competitive
soccer he's got the game on her on the
line she's dealt with all of this the
two-minute offense and all that so when
you get an athlete they come in there
you know former athlete or whatever I
don't think that's why I thought you
weren't nervous when I get nervous but
that's the kind of brilliance I think of
I do need those nerves ever liked you
ever
get nervous I'm like I get nervous even
when I'm doing an open mic but I think
for me that's like a trigger for my body
like that athletic that competitive
person where I'm like okay now go from
being scared to just like go like
perform as much as you can do the best
you can and then often times when I feel
the worst before a show if I'm sick or
if I don't want it you know that feeling
we're like I just want to be at home
right now and then I get onstage those
are the most fun shows just because it's
like you go from one end to the extreme
to the other which is the best yeah I
find if I'm yeah if I'm going to
anything like that then when it comes to
since I don't give a [ __ ] not the baddie
I think I don't give a [ __ ] about the
crowd but like I'm not going up there
with any sort of expectation of I want
to kill I got to follow this guy I'm
just like I don't feel like doing this
tonight I don't give a [ __ ] and then
what happens is you get so relaxed you
just fall into this pocket and lock in
with the crowd and after three jokes
personally I'm like cheese in ear to ear
like job ever yeah I always know I'm
having a good time when I look at
pictures and I'm like in like an ugly
deep gremlin SWAT squat and I'm like oh
yeah that was a good set you know cuz
I'm just like well I'm hoping this whole
stupid thing is gonna open up cuz you
know I did a special I guess it came out
in September but I mean I'm feeling like
you know I try to do one every couple of
years or so and this year just it's just
a it's kind of a loss but I'm thinking
well then maybe everybody else is gonna
be that way but I think everyone's
feeling that like it kind of a nice
thing about this is it's literally a
global pandemic so everyone's on the
same playing field I think you know like
everyone lost their job no ones are
getting to do shows if you are they're
like online shows which don't this is
just not the same thing so everyone else
puts out an album and you don't then I'm
gonna be in really interesting to see
what their process was in this whole
time I was making fun of those people
you know you say everybody's going
through this stuff I was making fun of
those people who do that [ __ ] where they
go this pandemic is especially hard for
me I'm such a social person it's just
like jeez is like wait you know wait
take the camera lens and just put it on
you yeah yeah that's for sure that's the
person to who shows up at all
that no one wants to talk to like
everyone else was happy there at home
that one person who's like I'm very
social you're like oh god just yeah and
then we already sit there we're all
bored out of our minds we're all losing
money we got to take time out to cheer
you up I'll say nothing that's been
bugging me is this just this overly
thanking of all the doctors and nurses
they're doing like the like the support
the troops thing this is what the troops
thing I understood because troops were
treated like [ __ ] after Vietnam
no one ever treated doctors and nurses
like [ __ ] maybe the doctors trees and
nurse suction is not a tyrant do a job
to have what are you talking Pete I mean
those people pulling in a paycheck you
know the thing I I'm like the people we
should be thanking are the grocery store
clerks who have no protection and who
are going in who like allow us to be
able to like get food and there's
they're still treated like [ __ ] and
they're still getting their minimum wage
or whatever issues who's treating them
like [ __ ] I don't walk a stick my
popsicles in the bag [ __ ]
well maybe not now but I think before
like I've been in grocery stores where
people are like talking on their phones
and not paying attention the person
trying to get like hey do you want pack
paper or plastic or whatever it is and
they're like treating them like they're
their servants doing I mean and I think
now that's switched we're like when you
have a plumber come here pipes leaking
all of a sudden the plumbers God you're
like whatever you want you know that's a
grocery store clerk I don't know I would
look at it like motivation to not be
bagging groceries because I had jobs
like that and getting treated like that
dishwasher and restaurants and well
they're gonna be blinging after this was
their sure it's only minimum wage but
they're like hey come on ladies mama's
got a job you know that's what I mean
it's just like I what I hate is people
how people like the new thing now is to
fall all over yourself thanking people
like ever since like 9/11 then it became
the the first responders to support the
troops now that now they got the doctors
in there and then they're gonna have the
people that bag groceries eventually
that that's going to be the end of
society is we're so gonna be like busy
thanking everyone around us so we don't
get in trouble
someone will check a nuclear reactor or
something I don't no one's thinking that
guy are you into conspiracy theory at
all I kind of got out of it and all of
my friends are sending me this [ __ ] that
it was created in a lab China did it on
purpose this is to take Trump down this
is to screw the Democrats this is
because the earth is flat I would say I
mean that people those people I think
are crazy but um the whole like this is
a conspiracy created in a lab there's a
lot of like you know bad things that are
created in labs but if this if the thing
is like it's creating a lot to take down
Trump this is the worst plan anyone's
ever come up with because it's just
taking down everybody like why why don't
you just create something that like he's
like Trump was exposed to it and didn't
get it so it's like it's really an
unsuccessful conspiracy theory if that's
the case he's too mean to get sick
[Laughter]
Trump is meaner than the virus I try to
try to remain apolitical and I just go
like crazy you know my own theories but
I got to admit once once he said this
shoot household cleaners into your body
I was like ah this guy yeah this guy's
got it guys I use three so I was like
that's ridiculous and then I thought my
mom is that she's retired now but she
was a microbiologist by trade and so she
dealt with like all this kind of stuff
you know anyone when it was coming up
she would be in the lab trying to like
tinker and figure things out and also so
this is woman who has her PhD in this
and also as a child she used to put
bleach on our tongue when we had a
canker sore because she's like it kills
the thing and I was like like this is
kind of this is what's giving me
perspective about like people who are
working the front lines of advice
perhaps trauma is getting I'm like if my
mom was involved she may have been like
yeah drink the cleaner isn't you know
it's just crazy to me well it sounds
like it so it's all about moderation
just a few simply doesn't that say like
you know have a nice little tumbler of
it it's just kind of rub it on our Mia
gums like things all they do in those
movies about cocaine yeah yeah yeah well
I wouldn't take his advice medically
even if he
if you weren't the president I wouldn't
that's not something I'd go to for
medical advice on how to stay healthy
and had a like you know so why would I
take it now I'm gonna wait for say just
watches ESPN all day and then Jesus
Christ and it looks like the loudest
phone ever hang on a second hang it's
the weirdest thing ever like the only
people who ever call my home phone just
delivery people or I would have met and
some sort of bad news it happens every
once in a while so sorry about that
anyways we talked about that the whole
Trump thing yeah yeah I just feel like
he just like watches ESPN all day and
then just at the last second like all
right you're on now how long do I have
to talk for when do I get the light this
goes up or he just starts said yeah this
that this thing again distinct repeated
but said a little more firmer he's sort
of blowing it off I don't know this one
is what I got it this thing has to end
because I'm gonna end up being this guy
that gets into [ __ ] politics and [ __ ]
and I don't want it it's funny not even
that I'm commenting on politics and I
haven't watched any of it yeah well
everyone I mean that's the thing as we
all have an opinion even though I live
with like my husband's very reads the
news you know he needs to know except
for his job and stuff like that and he
knows a lot about politics and things
and I'm just like I'll hear one headline
I'm like well I've got an opinion on
this and I'm gonna talk about it like
yeah it's just I mean also I can't vote
so I feel even more disempowered
Cousineau susan yet I have to I thought
why'd she get married you become a
citizen you have to wait like three
years but because I got my green card
two years before we got married if like
just on my own I think I have to wait I
can apply for next year or something but
I I can't I can't vote in Canada or in
America right now I'm just like a nobody
right now why do they view you like you
left them already yeah I think if you're
non-resident which I declared so I can
do my taxes here instead of there then
you're out of luck after a while a next
election you know all those idiots walk
around that stupid sticker I voted
mm-hmm you know like they're
potty-trained or something like that you
should
when I can't vote with a little sad face
on it
I the best is I love it because right
now when people try to campaign to me
and they stop come straight in like I
can't vote and they're like oh but I can
help you register I'm like not a citizen
and it's like I just breathes fire water
on them ok nevermind I don't want to
talk you know I'm gonna use that yeah
yeah I mean I think people know you're
my girl I know I just can't board I got
a felony this is when the next headline
bilborough's got a felony what could it
be and then okay
it's the refrigerator guy I got it I got
to go downstairs here for a second let
me talk to him let me talk to him huh
hang on a second it's just no there's no
respect for his own podcast whatsoever
all right well I like this this is
grainy or footage like I I'm more
castable is something else
hey Jake this is gonna [ __ ] huh did
you just move locations like this repair
guy came into our tiny flight of stairs
we have up we have stairs in our house
this house was a ninja initially just a
ranch and what happened was and then
there was a room downstairs and people
got sick of having to go outside to go
down to it cuz the house is like a
hundred years old so somebody just blew
out a closet hmm just stuck stairs going
down I can't believe I never noticed it
when I bought the [ __ ] myself so you
basically can't get anything down on the
stairs other than a person
Oh any furniture these stairs have to go
around its house and all that whatever
whatever it's my house hey when do you
think this thing's gonna be [ __ ] over
I want to go out on the road I've had it
my wife has had it with me I've had it
with me I just want to get back out
there everything starting to back up
they're just overhead lighting it's
great all right now I'm winded all right
and by the magic of editing now I'm
upstairs because of the [ __ ] back
upstairs again anyways why do you think
this thing's over I mean I don't know I
think that they're gonna start letting
people do eat like go and do things
again they're starting to reopen things
mostly just because otherwise people
gonna go crazy and that's the truth of
it they're not gonna be able to contain
people so I say like in another month
everything will be starting to open back
up which is scary right yeah yeah you
can't have like sixty percent of the
population become homeless because less
than 1% are sick so I think they they do
is they should just get a bunch of masks
and [ __ ] out to everybody specifically
older people people with asthma people
with weight issues
that's that thing weight issues yeah I
think that the worst health you're in
you know hey I'm not a doctor but I
still want to get thanked I'm gonna
throw some medical information out here
I don't get why they can't just get
everybody [ __ ] tested I don't
understand why that is so difficult you
got a ton of [ __ ] money for these
never-ending Wars you got plenty of
money to bail out these banker [ __ ] all
that but you can't just get us [ __ ]
tested find out who has the cooties and
who doesn't so there's one of them
there's like a non-emergency clinic that
undermine health care I'm allowed to go
to and they keep setting these messages
being like we've got tests and I don't
know if there's big black market like
not allowed this is before like
hospitals have them and they were like
you need to test let us know we're part
of your network and I was like oh my god
like what's gonna happen he's like and
then now they're like you they have the
antibody test like they're just like
setting these covert messages all the
time and I'm really wondering like where
they're getting them from but yeah I
don't like I don't like that vibe coming
from somebody in the medical field
yeah out of the back of a van yeah the
stolen stereo yeah like back in the day
can I look tell me about the whole your
your whole soccer background you played
professionally right yeah I mean
mm-hmm I played in University and then I
went to the World University Games it's
just like the Olympics for students
which was cool that was like probably
the for me one of the coolest experience
and then I played in the w-league which
doesn't exist anymore slow down slow
down so what happens you got the
University Championships how many we
okay so I played University I played for
all my eligibility and I did five years
and we went to Nationals three times one
once and came about silver twice so we
were like a very successful team
universe spell berta go pandas score any
any goals of course I did I mean come on
I did of course I was Israel for the
game-winner competitive in our national
chat and I scored once in it but the
game-winner we won 2-1 and the
game-winner was Cheryl Cormac another
another striker on our team but I scored
the first second is for the first one
she's for the second one but it was like
we that year when we won we were
undefeated
we had no losses only ties and wins and
then we went and won nationals and it
was like the break before we we had the
final game I remember being so emotional
and people are like are you ok are you
nervous I was like no I know we're gonna
win and I don't know what to do with
this energy like I'm like I'm so certain
I was just like that level of confidence
of like we were prepared we were the
best team I knew it and I was like on
top of my game and I was like let's just
get this over with
like let's get through the 90 minutes
cuz I wanna like hold the banner and
like go out and party cuz I'm just so
excited about it and then we want you
know I was cocky - I gave like I talked
to the press and I remember saying
things like yeah we're gonna win so
let's wrap it up like I was just so I
was the one you know you were given the
other team bulletin board material and
they still beat you like legit my my
last year we had a shitty year but we
still got to go to Nationals and then we
came in second and I gave a prayer I
talked to the press and I said we're
gonna drink happily either way meaning
if we wouldn't release we're proud of
her you know but what they wrote is
we're gonna drink happily and that was
posted in the newspaper and they
legitimately one of my girlfriends who
played on the team who played against
told me they brought that into their
pregame talk about a target on my face
being like let's do this
it was great but I mean like I don't
care I was like the best you know did
they try any cheap [ __ ] during the game
no I was wily like I was I was the one
who I'm like I'll punch me sure I'm just
gonna smile and I was wily I've never
heard that described in sports
no when he became a writer and a
comedian I would love to hear you
talking [ __ ] out on the pitch every to
understand half the things she was
saying I let my coach once told me she's
like I said you need to stop smiling so
much when you're playing because you
seem like a little [ __ ] disturber and
people are gonna come after you because
I would score and I'd be like ha ha like
just and like a little you know too
cocky for my own good but I delivered so
it was maybe that's what happened Isiah
Thomas if you've been watching this
Jordan Browder wants to get I've just
heard people commenting on it cuz I'm
like that was that whole year was my
final year of high school and we all
watched that at our graduation party so
I want to see this documentary of yeah
well but not to ruin it whatever there
was a whole thing with him being left
off the the dream team team and it still
bothers him and all that but like all I
remember about him other than he was a
great player was he was always smiling
he was like he had a great smile and he
seemed like he had it's funny he had
like this little kid vibe while being a
killer out there yeah and I don't know
what he did but he like somehow pissed
everybody off it seems and kind of me a
little bit maybe not to that extent but
cuz like I think they're the the team's
we played against we were vicious like
we used to like there were some real
elbows on purpose and stuff but as soon
as the game was done we were all cool
like we would be friends would go for
beer and all that kind of stuff so I
never had that long-term effect of not
making a team because people hated you
or something like that what's the
dirtiest thing you ever did to somebody
um I used to when I was running like
side-by-side and I was very fast back
then but you know you'd be standing next
to someone try not to get offside and
they would often try and grab at your
jersey so I would stand next to them and
hold their hand
and then they would kind of looking like
what the heck's going on as soon as the
ball went I would just lean down on
their hand which makes them fall like
this and then I would take off but I was
always like I felt justified in it
because they were grabbing at my drusen
doing this stuff mine was just like
sneaky in a different way at a different
time but I would be smiling the whole
time and like ah you know like well I
don't know that I kind of like fire I
always read sports books cuz I'm not the
brightest guy so I I was just reading
one on the Steelers and they were
talking about how one of the wives of
the offensive linemen like made their
jerseys a couple size smaller and then
put double-sided tape under the jerseys
and their pads yeah there's all kinds of
like that's what I always always strikes
me as funny when people talk about the
integrity of the game and all of that I
remember one time Sports Illustrated
this whole article on the biggest cheats
in the NBA oh that would be they had one
of the guys who was admitted a big cheat
in the NBA and he just went on
anonymously and he said okay so one
thing you try to do is you get yourself
between the ref and your opponent who
has the ball and you act like you're
reaching out to block the ball and you
actually you punch him in the balls and
the guy goes the writer was like you
punched him in the balls
he goes yeah he goes I learned that one
from Jordan so I think everybody I think
while the game is going on people do
[ __ ] and if they and they just look at
it like well it's the refs job to catch
me and if I get away with it I get away
with it I want a hundred percent believe
that that's not me look here's the thing
I'm not gonna cheat like you know women
we don't have balls to punch but I did
play with guys I played in the men in a
men's league over season like you know I
wasn't punching anyone in the balls or
in like that but I'm gonna do everything
I can to get the best advantage and if
it's against the rules then someone
should call me on it and if they don't
then I might keep doing it until you
know what you played it you played in a
co-ed league after that no I so I played
so I went played for university then I
played in the W League which was like
the professional women's league of North
America played in there two seasons and
then I went overseas to Korea
and played in a not a co-ed league it
was just I was you played you played at
a pro level in the United States well I
was in Canada and Canada and the Ottawa
team but we used to play at the
northeastern corner of the of America
and then we went to the final for both
seasons that I was playing Wow we didn't
amazing yeah it's kind of something like
it's a part of my life that I kind of
forget cuz I don't play soccer or watch
soccer now but I kind of forget that
that's a thing that's interesting to
people you know when you've done
something you're like that's just the
thing I did but that when someone here
it's already interesting but then
because she's so good at this new thing
you just thought ago she was the class
clown and she was socially awkward but
but you start filling in all it to like
like I did she's an athlete so she's not
nervous in the big moment and then
you're like oh I was completely you know
yes what might might whatever you call
your whatever yeah so I just assumed
that like I don't know I just always
just like assume that a lot of comics
had that sort of loner outcast not
fitting in thing well I loved your Rogan
story where it's like no I was I was a
national champion Taekwondo yeah then I
became a comedian
yeah but I think that there's something
about like for me I feel a little bit of
like this imposter syndrome in a way
sometimes because so many people what
socks when comedy were like I've always
wanted to be a comedian I'm a comedian
nerd I know all the comedian's every
special every word and like I just
didn't grow up watching comedy like my
family wasn't into that my dad my
parents weren't into that so I didn't
I'd never gone to see comedy until I
started doing comedy you know II mean
with Hannah how did you end up doing it
I started off so I was doing like
speaking stuff and then I got into
acting and then they were like there's
this opportunity to try stand-up and I
was like oh let me get outside my
comfort zone let me just try this thing
that's so scary to me and just get it
off the list of things that are scary
and do it one time and then I can feel I
don't know I'm more motivated to try new
things you know and then I did it and it
was
fun like I had a great time I love being
the center of attention for however long
as possible and then someone offered me
another show and I came off I was like
cool let me come back next you can do
that and then it was like a couple you
know shows and I did a couple shows in
that first couple months and someone's
like oh you're the one who does stand-up
comedy and I was like am i and then all
of a sudden I was getting more shows and
doing stuff this is in Winnipeg where
you know there's at the time there were
maybe three shows in a week if you were
lucky but it is the scene like there was
there a major chain comedy club like a
Yuk Yuk's or anything rumors rumors
common over so okay which is actually a
really great club I think a lot of
people like the actual club it's always
full they have shows I think like
Tuesday to Friday and it's always always
full but if I'm here like do it three
times to do stand-up and I had such a
great time to Winnipeg er to rumors
Winnipeg I never played rumors I played
a small theater up there Burton Cummings
theater I don't know it was like a
really old place I played a couple like
the I think it some more theater in
Seattle's the same way where they
haven't changed it and it's like well
over a hundred years old so they had
segregation oh yeah upper deck is like
the old like a separate set of stairs to
get all the way up there which is you
know is that glitch stairs do you use I
used the white privilege once right into
the back and I got my throat coati but
the joke I was doing was that's why
that's why black people dominated white
people in sports climbing all those
extra stairs and wheat and that's why we
have flat asses we just had to use
walked right into the no climbing
muscles no climbing muscles just came
walking in and sat down and enjoyed
ourselves yeah there was a there's a
couple that I've played one in wait Peck
was like that and then the one in
Seattle is like that and like I wanted
to see that way up or deck like well let
me see this see a party history let's
see these stairs it was no [ __ ] joke
I mean
this flight after flight yeah like I
can't imagine to like how weird the
energy of that crowd would be even
though it was considered this is the way
it is like you're coming out and as a
whole upper deck is black and the whole
bottom would be white is hilarious it's
like remember that with that mcdlt
sandwich where they had the hot side on
the cold side separately he's trying to
stick them together like there's
something about a crowd where you got to
get everybody on board I'm I wonder if
if entertainers would come backstage and
how were they yeah I didn't like the
upper deck at a lower deck they're a
little snobby tonight upper deck is fun
the lower deck I don't know I think
that's like a sketch for something me
like going back in the day and someone's
like killed it on that upper deck those
lower - yeah you know you have a comedy
team and the white hat brings the black
out on his shoulder he's performance to
the upper deck and you're doing the
lower than you're doing the same joke in
your own vernacular yeah oh my god looks
like I walk into this place is like the
top because like so I go around back to
where I'm allowed into this place and
[Laughter]
who would have ever thought I would miss
the road as motherf er I got mad at lady
the first two weeks of this pandemic
three weeks
I didn't MIT I did not miss stand-up at
all I'm like oh my call boho I don't
have to go to [ __ ] at LAX again I'll
take a month off but I kind of assumed
that everybody was just gonna stay
inside for two weeks burn out and now
what is it like a month and a half two
months I don't even know I don't know
what time is anymore but like yeah
everyone I think assumed it was just
gonna be this quick little break we're
all gonna get it like it was like a spa
treatment we'd all get more sleep we'd
be drinking less and then you know we'd
be well you're not you're not drinking
anymore are you
what's the deal nah not like you're so
disappointed in yourself like I will say
this so I quit cigars too because I
because those things what out of control
but
on Monday to Monday night I had my first
cigar in like two months
yeah and I went in and I was just like
just buy one so I bought and of course I
went in and I immediately bought two am
I doing it again and then this is so
weird I drink I drink the the Mexican
Fanta that has the real sugar okay I
drink one of those cuz it's the sweet
with the smoke you know they drink like
a smoky I think I saw you doing it on
your bill bill Bert Zoey yeah right a
Fanta that I was like Fanta interesting
yeah it's really probably white trash
but anyway well remember you have
Nigeria in Nigeria Santa's like the
thing all my family drinks Fantas I'm
like you see part Nigerian no okay so it
might be it's an idea that's a Nigerian
thing and it's a it's a anybody who was
alive in the 70s uh-huh
when I first remember Fanta first came
out and Sunkist orange soda when that
first came out and I remember I remember
this guy in the paper too a few years
later going son
you know he had just like you know a
bunch of rambling thoughts was his color
was his column that day and one of the
things that he wrote was Sunkist doesn't
taste as good as it used to and that was
the first thing I ever redness in a
newspaper that wasn't on a sports page
as a little person's just like I know
what this means
I know what this guy's talking about I
didn't know that that it meant it was
like fake soda so anyway so I bought two
cigars two sodas and that was Monday and
I was just so I kind understand how my
body works it's just like if I don't
[ __ ] with it for four days I don't give
a [ __ ]
so today's Thursday
so I got like one more day of this [ __ ]
and then that that cigar will stay there
I'm thinking July 4th weekend I'll smoke
one for merica right one for Mike but
that's also my kid's birthday so I'm
hoping we can at least be out doing
something else by then your son's
birthdays July 4th the 5th you I
wouldn't the labor on the 4th and then
he was born in between in between the
two earthquakes remember there was one
of the battle everyone that was back I
was I was back east I had an acting gig
yeah you're in New York something right
yeah yeah yeah for the
friggin summer so anyway let me let me
type the album again okay so it's called
all the parts and as of tomorrow May 8th
2020 but whenever you watch this it's on
iTunes Spotify all the places where you
get it you're absolutely killed I'm
dying to get out on the road and do some
stuff and I already promised you that
was gonna bring you out on a couple of
these so we both got little kids so yeah
you know hopefully people will stay
inside so that we can get on the road
everyone stay inside so that we can go
on the road and then I can come out and
go see us do it do it for us what is it
the doctors stay at home so they can go
out stay home so that we can go on the
road that's what I want thank God I'm up
for the outside bang the pots and pans
alright if you want a good laugh you
want to listen to me read out loud I
have to do a uh I got a doing a read
here what the hell is it okay all right
frame bridge everyone if you've been
listening to this show you've heard me
talk about frame bridge by now you know
that they make it super easy and
affordable to frame your favorite things
without ever leaving the house I have
I've actually used these people I have
my old dog Cleo do I got a nice framed
picture of her sitting up in my office I
still consider her my dog even though
she's not with me anymore anyway from
but they did a great job from art prints
and diplomas to the family photos
sitting on your iPhone you you can frame
bridge just about anything here's a
reminder how it works just go to frame
bridge comm and upload your photo or
they'll send you a package to safely
safely mail in your physical pieces I
guess that's for nudes you don't want to
see you don't to upload that preview
your item online and dozen of frame
styles choose your favorite or get free
recommendations from their talented
designers the experts at frame bridge
will custom frame your item and deliver
your finished piece directly to your
door ready to hang instead of hundreds
you pay at framing store their prices
start at $39 and all shipping is free
plus my listeners will get 15% off their
first order at frame bridge comm when
they use my code Barbie
get started today frame your photos has
sent someone the perfect gift go to
frame bridge calm and use the promo code
Barbie you are our to save an additional
15% off your first order just go to
frame bridge calm promo code burro once
again frame bridge calm promo code burr
alright there we go so that is the just
checking in your Thursday afternoon just
before Friday Monday morning podcast
cast ice is so great to finally have you
on here great to see you so good to see
you I know we were supposed to get the
kids together for the first time ever
and months ago it almost look it'll
happen it'll happen talking by then
it'll be great okay cool well I hope to
be out on the road with you soon working
on our new hours and I hope everybody
stays at home and this whole thing
[ __ ] blows out to sea alright so once
again if you want to see Ash's new album
go to iTunes and Spotify and it's called
all the parts I should thank you so much
thanks for being on here and I hope to
see you face to face in a packed comedy
club soon yeah alright we'll see you bye
bye hey what's going on it's bill burr
and it's the Monday morning podcast for
Monday May 7th 2012 2012 babies what's
going on do you guys have a why am i
yelling why am i yelling you know why
cuz I got a good night's sleep and I
just had some waffles so I got that
[ __ ] sugar rush yeah I made Oh just
slammed my computer gives a [ __ ] I can't
figure out how to work it anyways I had
I had some waffles for breakfast now why
did you just shut off your [ __ ] oh I see
it just sort of Jesus bill everything
that technology does is not an attack on
you why don't you just relax
I mean I'm hang on guys I just need to
talk to myself for a second alright
alright I'm back yeah it's some [ __ ]
waffles actually made them yesterday
let's take you guys through my boring
day
it sounds like the beginning of a Bruce
Springsteen song doesn't it it's so
awful it was over crass but I was gonna
make him Sonny shot up oh my god how
does he turn it around the breakfast
limericks from that guy you know what
it's one of my goals to see him live in
concert because I've been making fun of
him forever and half of my friends have
been making fun of him and then they go
see him in concert and they're like dude
you got to go see that guy in concert
you know with his class three underbite
he's got he's got a he's got one of
those I don't know if he was a dog
keeping with those dogs with the most in
faces you know he's got one of those
boxer the same dentition like a boxer or
like a pug what the [ __ ] can't get did
pugs not breathe or something I know
they have the motion face but like I
always hear Bulldogs have the worst time
trying to breathe but like pugs have the
most look of panic on their face like
when Bulldogs can't breathe they just I
asked they just seemed like a tub of
[ __ ] dog we're like pugs like genuinely
seemed concerned about something the way
their eyes bug out or do they have like
that high metabolism you know when you
have something wrong with your thyroid
is that the right word huh
do I have any doctors that listen to
this anyways I made waffles yesterday
and the lovely Nia is killing it you
know she's working out she's on this I'm
gonna be a [ __ ] even hotter chick diet
right so she can't eat anything all
right anything and you know the ladies
okay they got all that [ __ ] hormonal
[ __ ] going on every goddamn month you
know stuff [ __ ] I don't know what
there's always something going on with
them you know they're basically it's
like living with an addict when you live
with the woman you know they always guy
he's got some [ __ ] coming up and they
always that same [ __ ] so now you
compound it with the fact now she's on
some special diets so she's basically
detoxing from whatever [ __ ] you know
how people eat you know we right you get
the sugar salt rush you eat till you're
totally stuffed you mentally think
that's what eating is so then when you
actually eat the way you're supposed to
and your body isn't like freaking out
like yeah
free those right it's actually just
chillin with some [ __ ] broccoli and
some protein you're not used to that you
know you're used to going to some
high-energy [ __ ] so anyways I'm sitting
there making the waffles right and you
don't want those deals when you check
those on a [ __ ] diet all of a sudden
you have to be on the diet too you know
oh my god I have to sit here I see one
John's super hey my fault you know I'm
not on a diet and then they do all that
[ __ ] where they always try to make it
seem it's easier to be a guy guys can
lose weight so it's easier it's so much
harder for a woman that bah bah bah bah
bah it's not enough I'm gonna die before
you do okay what is your problem with
the soup jesus [ __ ] christ
Jesus Christ so anyways that's what I'm
[ __ ] dealing with and I actually had
a major victory there's one of those
silent victories that you have in your
relationship you know those are the best
ones to have you don't say anything and
you see it in their face and you see
that they realize it and then you see
them wondering if you realize it and you
kind of look back and I'm like I do
realize it but I'm not going to say it
because then you'll be able to if I say
it out loud you somehow [ __ ] do some
sort of two-point reversal and bring up
some other [ __ ] and then I'll lose you
know I'll just [ __ ] shoot that look
right back at you like that's right
woman I won this one okay you're gonna
have to wait for another fight because
this one is over this [ __ ] Michael
Corleone's says in The Godfather - I got
a I got to steal that at some point I
want to be an argument with Mia I can't
be a real one cuz she'll get mad I'm
just gonna do it over something stupid
like she wants to go see this cabin in
the woods [ __ ] movie whatever the
hell it is it supposed to be a perfect
movie
what does that mean the guy gives in to
the woman oh Jesus am I in a [ __ ] mood
can I blame it on the syrup here people
it was the syrup of Jersey I can't say
out in Jersey that's Anthony's
impression of him
I owe him [ __ ] 50 cents right there
some residuals um Anthony qu Mia
everybody from the Opie and Anthony
program with little Jimmy Norton on XM
satellite radio a little promo the [ __ ]
was I just talking about god dammit
play bit on the syrup [ __ ] that thoughts
gone oh I know I had this minor victory
had this minor victory right I'm on the
road on the route again right doing my
dick jokes on the road again I don't
give a [ __ ] about you or your friend buy
my DVD and get the [ __ ] out of my face I
should have [ __ ] waffles you know
what this little podcast it's gonna die
in like [ __ ] 12 minutes and I'm just
gonna sugar crash I'm gonna be laying on
the rug like that [ __ ] dude and
Trainspotting but instead of like
falling into it I'm just gonna nod off
like a [ __ ] like a goddamn dog with a
moist and face oh he brought it around
what's the do so anyways yeah it was the
victory I had so I was on the road doing
my jokes I come back to town alright and
and as always somehow when I was away
something got broken and nobody knows as
any [ __ ] idea it's like my car I
don't know what happens when I take it
out nobody ever really hits it somehow
when Nia takes it out somebody always
hits it and then I go out she doesn't
say [ __ ] I go out to use the car and I
see some sideswipe down the [ __ ] side
of the car and I just go I come in I go
Nia somebody hit the car and that she's
always like what when did that help how
many times can I fall for that yet do
people just not like you when you drive
the car that what am I talking about
somebody tagged it a [ __ ] month ago
when I went over crisp orders somebody
[ __ ] tagged my car
but anyway so I come back and once again
something's broken the blender the
blender was busted
you know the engine worked but the
little [ __ ] T things were broken so
she's just like we need a new blender I
can't make my Skinnygirl margaritas
anymore because the teeth don't work so
let's throw the but the [ __ ] motor
works so I go a little one we just get
it fixed and she's like cuz she knows
what that means why don't we get a fix
that means it's gonna sit there for
three years before I finally bring it
over to a repair shop alright but not
not now that old new fix-it Billy I said
you know what I'm gonna figure out how
to [ __ ] fix that goddamn thing
all I did you know what it was all I
just wanted all you have to do is just
look up the [ __ ] you get the I know
this is basic to some people but for a
lot of morons and there's a lot that
listen to this podcast by the way
no offense none taken all you do is just
whatever the brand and then the serial
number you go on the internet and you
can you just buy the part so I buy the
[ __ ] part thing shows up I do all
this [ __ ] without talking in here right
and I [ __ ] I go to take this thing
apart turn it upside down and [ __ ]
pull it and trying to pull the motor on
and won't come out because that thing on
the top and I'm like what the [ __ ] and
then it's going YouTube and I found a
video of a guy doing fixing the exact
problem I had I didn't need to unscrew
the bottom all I need to do is just
[ __ ] get a screwdriver and take the
thing off the top which how it doesn't
strip the top I have no [ __ ] idea
we don't care bill get to the point all
right long story short I get this
[ __ ] thing on it works so what do I
do
do I get in her face and say yeah woman
I [ __ ] fix that [ __ ] I don't I don't
I fix it make sure it runs I try it out
and then I just stick it in a cupboard
you know and a couple days later I go
yeah you know what I think I'd like a
milkshake well how you gonna do that the
blender doesn't work
oh I fixed it
[Music]
you fix yeah I fixed it as no big deal
took it apart I got a [ __ ] fix to
myself there you go woman all right with
your hole we need to [ __ ] go buy
another one you know I realize that
wasn't really a major victory even
though like when you just in your head
you're like yeah I [ __ ] dominated
then I just said that out loud that was
really no big deal
the seventh is how much I wanted to fix
it it was a $7 part and I had it
overnighted for like [ __ ] 16 bucks so
you know and I didn't even want a
milkshake I just wanted to show that I
did something I don't know why why
because I'm a weak person and I need
other people's approval there does that
make you happy does that make you feel
does that make you smile and your
[ __ ] cubicle huh
is that what you're doing when you're in
a cubicle and you're smiling if I was
your boss I would immediately think that
you're somehow stealing from the company
because there's no reason to smile on a
computer in a cubicle in a computer in a
cubicle there's no [ __ ] reason all
right unless you somehow figured out a
way to be happy you know
some sort of those Zen douche bags why
they do SH bag bill because they're
happy you know what happened to you all
right what the [ __ ] am I gonna talk
about I was gonna do oh I know we have
to talk about everybody this is very
special guess what it is this Sunday
it's Mother's Day Mother's Day your mom
the one that that did most of the heavy
lifting as far as bringing you into the
world your dad was like the Steve Jobs
you know yeah I want this to happen
get on it scientists right so he had a
partner too you know although they never
bring that up on the view do they
believe it or not this is advertising
all right let's get on with this
ProFlowers everybody Mother's Day it's
coming up all right it's Monday it's
Sunday you know what that means
it means it's only six days away so what
does that mean that means you go down to
the drugstore all the good cards are
gone at this point they're all picked
over all the envelopes are laying on the
ground and the only cards that are left
are either they that just you know it's
like a fart joke or they're like
oddly incestuous you know there's no
good cards left
once again you screwed up all right so
what do you got a deal
the ladies they like the flowers all
right so here's the copy uh guys don't
mess up on Mother's Day if you will like
me you probably put it through the
ringer as a kid
DUI now show her that you love her and
send her flowers from plov ProFlowers
it's a great way of making up to mom is
by sending her flowers from ProFlowers
everybody come on man you got to do it
you got to do it I'm gonna do it don't
you want to be like me this is the deal
you get a dozen rainbow roses for Mom
plus a free glass vase for only $19.99
an incredible piece and they are
guaranteed to last seven days all right
bing bang boom this is you know what's
great about ProFlowers is you get to
handle this you get to feel like what
it's like to be a rich guy you don't I
mean you know rich people are always
working on their business and they don't
have time they don't have time to go out
and buy gifts so they just sent some
assistant out whose birthday is it I did
go get my Maserati
and you see I'm busy in here you can do
the same thing for a much cheaper price
for $19.99 you can handle your mom like
a rich guy running a business what's it
my mother she brought me into the world
you go out there let me tell you
something you go out there for $19.99
you get out of some rainbow roses in a
vase I'm gonna get back to my job here
all right this is why you got to do go
to proflowers.com you click on the mic
and you type in the code be URR it's my
last name for all the slow people out
there and for my radio listeners you can
get another dozen roses plus chocolates
for just $10 more that's 40% off so
there you go flowers and chocolates okay
and then you don't have to go pick them
up they're gonna deliver them right to a
door all right
all you got to do is just type in bar
click on the Mike on the top of coat top
what click on the Mike and type in the
code bar I can't read all right
here we go either call 1-800 ProFlowers
that's it you can do it over the phone
go light up a giant cigar and act like
you're running a corporation here call
eight 1-800 ProFlowers or even better
visit proflowers.com click on the
microphone in the top right corner and
type in bur be URR that's proflowers.com
and that's it open now for mother's day
o order now for mother's day before the
deal is gone alright before the deal is
gone and then all you gotta do is you
that stuff shows up and you take out to
breakfast you give her a big hug you
apologize for your DUI you know tell her
she's the best and that's it
you got another year of unconditional
love thanks to the wonderful people at
proflowers.com I challenge you to find a
better read umm alright moving on here
moving on what the hell am I gonna talk
about oh you know I went I went into a
bar last night Oh yesterday afternoon
cuz the games come on early because I
finally accepted the fact emotionally
that my Boston Bruins have been knocked
out of the Stanley Cup Playoffs and I've
actually you guys know my hatred of NBA
basketball you know I don't hate I don't
hate it I just that final three minutes
it drives me nuts
with all the timeouts and I know I
brought it up before any what's even
worse is when they call the timeouts I
noticed yesterday because I watched a
game is then they start reading copy you
know like anything they can do to just
bring the drama all the way back down to
zero
it's like tied [ __ ] 98 98 oh they got
they got 28 fouls to give and then they
follow and so-and-so calls the timeout
and then next thing you know they're
sitting there reading you know like what
I just did bro flowers calm guess your
mother some [ __ ] you know that's
stupid I don't know so anyways I've
accepted the fact that the Bruins are
out of the playoffs and I'm alright well
the bees are out Joe why don't we go
watch the [ __ ] C's kid you know what
I'm saying
so Celtics were playing the Atlanta
Hawks who used to be the st. Louis Hawks
and we beat them in 1958 I believe for
their NBA title that's right st. Louis
we owned your ass in a sport you don't
even know about
more back when Eisenhower was in office
so I watched that game it was it was
just a phenomenal playoff game as far as
like being a fan because it was over
before it even started
you know it was over and there was never
a concern they were up by 30 points and
I sat there drinking beer and eating
wings becoming [ __ ] Oh fat boy Billy
again Billy fat again
that's my Irish neighbor so so I'm
sitting there right I'm with the bloody
mind
right watching the game I'm having a
great time right like the fourth quarter
these four girls four five girls coming
and it's a dive bar you know I like the
dive bars you can get a place to sit you
know it's just one of those deals
somebody has one of those [ __ ] what's
Nick Nolte's character in 48 hours you
know there was there's always one of
those cars parked out front some [ __ ]
piece of [ __ ] rag top with some sad dog
in the backseat right I like those bars
you know the barf like car right so I
walk in there we're watching the game
and like [ __ ] with like I don't know
five minutes to go in the game so what's
that like two hours NBA time these like
five six chicks come in and they're just
like they're just train wrecks all of
them wearing pants we can just see their
clams
you know ridiculously tight pants and
other girls got these cut-offs with this
her hat turns sideways looking like
she's in some [ __ ] Fresh Prince video
in the late 80s
it's just they were just absolute messes
and they start putting money into the
jukebox and they just starts singing all
they started sing along to video killed
the radio star right and then they just
start you know and then there's all
these [ __ ] old guys barfly [ __ ]
Jack offs like my age and a little bit
older like way too [ __ ] old for these
chicks right and these girls are being
like really [ __ ] loud and they're
[ __ ] dancing with each other and they
have grabbing each other's asses doing
all this [ __ ] and you see these guys up
at the bar they lie
they start like reacting to this sex
[ __ ] energy depth they're putting out
this so two of the girls stand up they
start that's what I got dude it was like
the [ __ ] accused like times five was
going down the whole vibe was [ __ ]
ridiculous so the two girls stand up
they start like dancin grinding up
against each other and then one of the
guys eventually like some big [ __ ]
sex star bear starts walking over and
starts pawing at the girl and then the
girls like hey knock it off get the [ __ ]
out of here right and my buddy
classic looks at me and goes she
facilitated that entire [ __ ] thing
and it's like exactly thought it was I
don't know if there was strippers I
don't know what the [ __ ] deal was but
it was just one that thing that I've
always said we gotta have responsibility
for your own [ __ ] safety obviously
that guy shouldn't just feel that he
should be able to walk over and start
pawing at some girl but you know when
you're sitting there with your clam
[ __ ] outlined on the front of your
[ __ ] jeans and you're grinding up
against her your friend and you're
pulling her jacket off and she's gonna
stop it stop it and you keep pulling it
off I mean what the [ __ ] do you thinks
gonna happen you know I [ __ ] you know
there's nothing worse than when people
act like the world is a perfect place
and then they act shocked when something
bad happens it isn't okay this the way
you wish the world was and the way it is
so [ __ ] act accordingly you don't go
in there with your [ __ ] hoo-ha
hanging out and start grinding up on
your friend in front of [ __ ] five
drunk guys who wouldn't women haven't
done a double take at since the [ __ ]
I don't know Fernando Valenzuela struck
out this side okay it was just it was a
really [ __ ] uncomfortable vibe and I
literally looked at my friend I go look
we don't get out of here in three
minutes we're gonna be testifying in
about [ __ ] six weeks for whatever
bullsh it's about ready to go down and
you know what kills me is knowing that
the bar stopped them from doing what
they were doing you know I was trying to
think what the [ __ ]
version of what they were doing would be
I guess it would be like acting
aggressive and almost causing like a
fight vibe
alright but you know then you get tossed
out but women could can create the
accused vibe and I don't know I'm
probably gonna get [ __ ] for this but
like you know I'm not advocating what
that guy did that what that guy did was
[ __ ] wrong but Jesus [ __ ] Christ
what did your dad do did heave up by
like fisher-price how to be a [ __ ] did
they make like remember those little
[ __ ] stereos they made did they make
like a [ __ ] the [ __ ] version of that
I don't know I'm at that age people I'm
at that age where I look at women like
that and I don't go like well there's an
easy mark I now look at them going like
at Jesus Christ wait [ __ ] was your dad
what didn't he do but anyways what was
actually funny was for some this is how
drunk they were as they were grinding on
each other and [ __ ] pulling up each
other's dresses and doing all this [ __ ]
the [ __ ] for whatever reason uh I
don't know where they just started
singing the star-spangled banner and
then the guys at the bar joined in and I
have video of it I'm gonna send it to my
guy and hopefully we'll get it up on the
site I got it like halfway through they
sang the whole [ __ ] song and what was
funny was that whole [ __ ] is somebody
gonna get raped vibe went out the window
both sides for like a good three minutes
were in harmony with some sort of
support the troops vibe just out of
[ __ ] nowhere and I this is the funny
thing about it this was probably like
7:00 in the evening this is how [ __ ]
wasted everybody was alright plowing
ahead here um oh whatever women what do
you think about that am I being the
[ __ ] caveman there I'm not advocating
that that I'm saying that those guys are
they did was right but like you can't
that's like it's like me like I've
always said this that's like me walking
through Central Park at like 3:00 in the
morning dressed like Liberace singing
I'm in the money I'm in the money
right and then someone comes up smashes
me over the head I get a concussion I
got it [ __ ] Mike cheekbones [ __ ] up
you know they take my wallet you know
and all that [ __ ]
is it wrong yes do you feel bad for me
yes but what the [ __ ] was I thinking you
know why don't you just [ __ ] give
yourself a bunch of paper cuts and jump
jump in shark-infested water and then
[ __ ] go and then it bit my leg off
you're an [ __ ] that's that's my side
of it relationship advice follow-up
success story dearest dearest Billiam
you may or may not remember a couple
months ago I emailed you about some
relationship advice to recap 22 years
old been with my girlfriend for seven
years most of it long distant smallish
things had happened from time to time
which made me doubt I could trust her I
gave the example of the strip poker
thing she lied about and the business
trip where she said a co-worker tried to
kiss her oh yeah I got to be honest with
you dude I get a lot of emails like that
so uh and I've been that guy I was that
guy when I was 23 anyways he goes you
sent me a very clear message pulled the
ripcord I'm just writing to let you know
that I did take your advice and although
it was probably the hardest thing I've
ever had to do it was a hundred percent
the right call so thank you for giving
me the extra nudge I needed hopefully in
the future I can be a [ __ ] man about
these things and you just do what needs
to be done I'm through most of the
relationship fallout now I did have to
tell her to get [ __ ] when she kept
wanting to get back together she didn't
seem to understand that all of the
reason we broke up would still be there
bottom line I'm happier than I've been
in a long time thanks man oh yeah well
there you go and that's the hardest
thing to is when they're coming back to
you because as you're thinking is your
brain up top is going this is wrong
you're out
stay out your dick is going free [ __ ]
all right that's what you dick say so
you have to override that and I gotta be
honest with you the only reason why she
was
getting back with you was just to get
with you till she was mentally prepared
to walk away from you so she could pull
the ripcord and that's the worst so you
avoided all that so now this is what you
do son go out and have a good time and
don't get involved with anybody that you
don't feel you're gonna marry alright is
this the mother of my kids
alright go [ __ ] yourself and that's how
you do it until you meet the one that is
and then that's the one that's the one
you give you heart to but other than
that [ __ ] all of them [ __ ] them
alright I don't mean that misogynistic
way but just you know when you [ __ ]
you know two three dates in and the day
it doesn't feel [ __ ] weird you know
it's this start doesn't feel right I
mean and it's still feeling weird you
know at that point all she has at your
place is maybe a scrunchie or some sort
of [ __ ] toiletry they just get it's
out done there you go beat it
and you don't have to be mean you just
be honest just say listen I I really
like you you're a nice person I just
don't see this long-term so rather than
waste your time and my time and us both
getting really hurt we'll just just
leave right now
this is I believe this is yours alright
good for you sir
good for you alright here we go pissed
off Bay Area fan who mice whose also
might be cops what all right thanks for
canceling the Sunday show in San Jose
you ginger [ __ ] oh yeah I'm doing San
Jose coming up and I had to I could I
can't do the Sunday show I had to cancel
that one so evidently this guy says at
least ten of us bought tickets to the
show and as a boozy and had a boozy work
night night out planned around it to say
we were looking forward to it would be
an understatement
we are not some random group of amateurs
either we are dedicated fans faithful
podcast listeners we came out to see you
last time you were in San Jose and we
even stood in line to meet you
bye-bye the DVDs and buy the DVDs man
and some of us were even women and not
only that we actually we've actually
been polarized polarizing on behalf on
your behalf and one used several or
several new fans who also bought tickets
to the sunday show one guy's [ __ ] wife
only allows him out one night per year
and this was going to be his 2012 out in
Jesus Christ dude you're killing me
we've told him you're a stand-up guy how
do we tell him you've thrown us over and
are scurrying out to Chicago to suck up
to Vince Vaughn douche move mister /
douche move hey what about the other two
nights I'm going there first of all stop
acting like San Jose is like some blue
chip [ __ ] City all right
San Jose only can look down to
Bakersfield you look an eye to eye at
Sacramento all right you're both the
chicks with the good personalities all
right but we all know the hottie is San
Francisco okay listen I apologize yeah
it's something I have to do it'll make
sense in a few months it'll make sense
in a couple of months why I had to do
what the [ __ ] I'm doing I don't talk
about the [ __ ] that I that I'm doing
because most of it it doesn't get picked
up
it gets swatted back down to the ground
so why [ __ ] bring up oh hey I just
did this and allegedly it has the
opportunity to do that and then nothing
happens and then it's bad enough it
doesn't happen then you have to deal
with people going hey whatever happen to
that thing oh it's it failed it crashed
and burned so I yeah I have to go to
Chicago it's a [ __ ] loyalty thing all
right you think I wouldn't like to spend
another [ __ ] night in San Jose I love
San Jose I don't like the shots I don't
like your hockey team I respect your
fans though you got great fans up there
so I'm sorry I'm sorry Julie Jim Dave
Mikey Joey Joey's girlfriend Rico Bill
and several others all right you [ __ ]
babies
and he goes no we can't let PS no we
can't just come Friday Saturday shows
instead because we work those nights
we're in a local law enforcement oh [ __ ]
they have guns um yay my fault I'll make
it up to you and I'll see you at the
policemen's ball there's no way we can
get the night off
Saturday and Sunday night was it man all
right all right I [ __ ] you over what
you think I'm not coming back
[ __ ] you know what you're good you got
me with the guilt you did you got me
with the guilt hey how about those LA
Kings everybody's anybody else watching
of the [ __ ] playoffs the LA Kings for
the first time since the Gretzky era and
as far as I know I didn't look this up I
think only the second time in their
history they've made it to the Western
Conference Finals at least as far as
when I've been paying attention I don't
ever remember him there back when they
had those yellow and purple Laker
jerseys on I don't know
and the kunti Devils keep beating the
Flyers I thought the Flyers I'm not
saying it's over God knows it's not over
when it's the [ __ ] fliers it came
back down oh three against my Bruins but
the Devils are just so [ __ ] kunti you
know what I mean
and I mean that with all due respect I
hate it when they played the trap and
all that type of [ __ ] but sons of
[ __ ] man they played very they played
like that disciplined hockey but
disciplined all right let's plow ahead
here what do we got what do we got next
is it racist racist racist mushnick
edition what is this man [ __ ] a mushnick
it's a Murdock on paper
enough said what is mushnick what the
[ __ ] is what is this throwback is it
racist mushnick edition I have no idea
what this means says as long as the nets
are allowing jay-z to call their
marketing shots what a shock that he
chose black and white as the new teen
colors to stress as the Nets explained
their new urban home
why not have him apply the full JZ
treatment why the Brooklyn Nets when
they they can be the New York n-words
what the [ __ ] is this
the cheerleaders should be the Brooklyn
[ __ ] or hoes team logo a 9-millimeter
what the [ __ ] is this oh oh oh oh this
is film Mushnik Oh Phil Mushnik wrote
this Oh
okay Phil Mushnik is this guy who's just
he's never in a good mood he could be
getting a two on one on a sunny day in
the middle of winter and he would still
find a reason to complain about stuff
and that's funny coming from me because
I'm one of the biggest concert ever was
all right Phil Mushnik this is what he
wrote about jay-z owning the nets in
Brooklyn okay now I get it he says as
long as the Nets are allowing jay-z to
call their marketing shots well why
shouldn't they it's America he had the
money but the team what a shock that he
chose black and white as the new team
logos to stress as the Nets explain
their new urban home why not have him
imply the full jay-z trait treatment why
the Brooklyn Nets when they could be the
New York New York n-words the Chili's
could be the Brooklyn [ __ ] or hoes
team logo a nine-millimeter with hollow
tips shell casings strewn beneath wanna
be jay-z hip and go all the way at Jesus
that's just stupid
well isn't black and white isn't that
inclusive like there's only black and
white people in Brooklyn but I'm just
saying you know why say 9 millimeters
there's a whole Hasidic population
there's the growing up gaudy population
out there
Brooklyn is uh-oh Phil I think he is he
just anyways he says bill is this racist
there's this asian girl that I work with
who has a bit of an eye condition that
is [ __ ] oh this is a whole different
thing I thought this guy was tying that
in I'm sorry I'm just a [ __ ] idiot
right now I told you the Serpent's was
wearing off the sugar rush or whatever's
[ __ ]
wearing down here yeah why did he do
that is he trying to be the next who's
that guy with the cowboy hat now
murderer
that guy he's mad that that their colors
are black and white what is wrong with
black and white it's like the Nets had a
classic uniform I thought then their
uniform was hideous they had that group
that gray with the red and the white was
awful I think it's cool if there's a
team in Brooklyn oh film Mushnik why
don't you go get yourself a Sunday you
have miserable bastard alright coming
from me alright bill is this racist
racist there's this asian girl that I
work with who was a bit of an eye
condition that is slightly but
definitely noticeable she's not cross I
out she's not cross-eyed but something
is definitely askew you can tell she's
looking at you but one eye kind of
drifts off into no-man's land yeah lazy
eye now normally googly eyes would be a
pretty big turnoff right but she almost
seems more or luring because of it this
had me wondering if Asian women can pull
off this look better than other
nationalities a mainstream example of
this would be Lucy Liu she had set and I
think going on I'll be it a slight thing
but she's revered as a hottie
compare that to a Caucasian Bobbie
Bobbie bet SIA the CNN anchor that Nancy
walls did an impression of or
african-american Stuart Scott a lesser
example considering he's a male is it
racist of me to believe ajun may have
the edge when it comes to public
overlooking their lazy eyes if so do you
think it's due to their eyes being all
mushy
thus detracting from the wonkiness ah
Jesus dude I think you just think this
girl is hot you know and you'd rather
bang her than Stuart Scott I think it's
really that simple I don't know I don't
know who half those other people are I
don't watch CNN or Fox News I find it
I don't know I just find both those
they're totally slanted in opposite
direction so I never watch that [ __ ] and
that Stuart Scott is battling for his
life I believe so I don't know dude I
think you just want to [ __ ] I think
you just I just think you want to bang
this girl I think that's why you I think
you like Asian chicks regardless of
whether their eyes are looking at you
are not looking at you you you like them
so you know when I say sir I say go for
it you know go get yourself a beautiful
girl you know it's great she can Bob
because Linda I was gonna do an easy
joke that I'm not doing it all right
okay here we go
bill I want to bang lesbian friend who
is in lesbian remission
Jesus okay this is outside my realm but
I'll try and answer it hey Bill
I want your opinion on this problem I
have I'm a 19 year old college freshman
and I'm in a bit of an ethical dilemma I
have this friend who is a lesbian and
recently she has been she hasn't been
having any luck with the ladies so now
she's feeling vulnerable to the point
that she's active actually contemplating
about [ __ ] this guy she knows after
she tells me this I start getting
jealous because I've always had sexual
feelings for her but never acted on them
because she's a lesbian and I respected
her dude what kind of a [ __ ] [ __ ]
are you you know why are you hanging out
with her we were just waiting for
daylight what what are you doing she's a
lesbian she doesn't want to [ __ ] you you
just sitting it's a dried up well it's
over walk away what else is it well I
guess she's a lesbian maybe she's into
some I don't know does she fix cars like
you I have no idea what is there
anything worse than a guy just hovering
around you know rather than going out
and just like I don't know what you're
waiting for just plenty of fish in the
sea in 19 well you know what I'm being
too hard on you you're 19 years old you
have no idea
hello Cleo hey Mia can you help me out
with this one
oh you got to go real quick you know
gotta go this guy's trying to bang this
lesbian girl who's in lesbian remission
it means she hasn't she's wanted to like
hook up with some other ladies but
they're not giving it to her so she's
actually been contemplating [ __ ] this
other guy so now this dude's jealous
because he's always been hanging around
her I mean that conversation we had
earlier
that's what guy guys hang around women
either the gay guy or they're trying to
[ __ ] you if there's really no other
alright why wish you could hang you all
right go have fun huh all right that's
nice though your fans thought that you
were coming on and now you're not you
leaving them wanting more you leave it
and wanting more can we do this real
quick okay so I told you what's going on
Cleo get out of here anyways but now
that she's in the mood to go to going
back to [ __ ] dudes some other douche
is feeling her up even before I knew
what was happening so this other guy got
in there he goes I don't want to make
her my girlfriend we both made it very
clear neither us are good at being in
relationships because we're both selfish
people I do not want however I do want
to [ __ ] her once and I tried asking my
cousin for his point of view on the
situation but he recently found Jesus Oh
yeesh so the only answer to give he
gives me is read the Bible or premarital
sex is a sin what do you think should I
sleep with her before she [ __ ] this guy
and realized she doesn't like men and
ruin any chance I have uh wait should I
try I'll try try to sleep with her
before this guy [ __ ] her and she
realizes she doesn't like men a ruin any
chance I have or should I just go just
be the friend and do nothing
Thanks are there no other women around
for you to [ __ ] that you're just
completely singularly focused on and
obsessed with this girl who's a lesbian
that's exactly what I said why are you
hovering around her that's what is it
because you can't have her or like it's
it's a it's a chase thing or it's a
struggle that he's like you know what it
is I bet they're the same the same
height and they can borrow each other's
clothes
I was wondering were you gonna wear that
flannel tonight because I feel like
getting
involved sexually with anyone who's
having like going back and forth with
their sexuality and figuring out it's
probably not a good idea that's cuz
there's probably a lot of emotional [ __ ]
going on along with that that she may
not talk about and you may not be aware
of I would just leave them yeah why
don't you just go talk to a girl that
wants to bang a guy once you make it a
lot you make it a lot easier hey how do
I turn this bus into a bicycle I've
always wanted this bus to be a bicycle
and uh now it's men like the chase
though right you know we like a layup we
like a layup about the chase and make it
difficult and all that I know that's
what you guys are into you guys are into
just making it difficult we want you
guys just to [ __ ] just blind stop
acting like it doesn't feel good for you
to you know know you know what it is
there there is as far as like a good
feeling is when a woman is making it
difficult and you tear through all that
[ __ ] and you're able to make her
succumb you're rolling your eyes Nia
right you've experienced that haven't
you well yeah the speech that you give
before you tell people like oh you what
you are making it difficult that it was
a [ __ ] blocking me and I [ __ ] try
that that that right there is like
remember that year when when Tom Hanks
went back-to-back Oscars he's still a
great actor but you know is that ever
gonna happen again that's that's my
that's my sexual conquest the night I
brought you down brought you down like a
[ __ ] wildebeest on the Serengeti see
what they do they just take it away Cleo
come on well that's my that's my two
cents okay so I'm gonna go now okay
all right I'll see you have fun all
right the [ __ ] female Robocop if I
can work it out like a maniac I'm over
here becoming a tub of [ __ ] that's right
all right I see you later so there you
go sir this is what I think you should
do we basically both of us you got to
stop hanging out with these girls that
why you doing that you know
I know why you doing it I know why
you're doing it cuz you can be like dude
my dick is so intoxicating even chicks
adult-like dick can't say no to my dick
alright let's read some advertising
shall we people let's get on with it
where the hell is it here oh Christ
where are we where are we okay here we
go here we go oh the usual stamps calm
everybody we've done this one before
this is what this is this is the runaway
advertising hit on the podcast here
everybody's getting into it and by the
way you know I heard it I hid her story
neiha always listens to NPR she always
listens to that yeah all things
considered today we're gonna talk about
how strawberries are made the strawberry
doesn't everybody enjoy 2-stroke Jesus
ntr good lord
it's a [ __ ] bore fest right she
always has it on so I [ __ ] sit there
and I listen to it you know and but they
were talking about the post office and
how it's bankrupt and how they're gonna
be chained they're gonna be closing a
bunch of them soon and at least this is
what they was saying unless they're
super busy they're going to be closing
them so why don't you get the jump ok
get the jump and go to stamps calm and
bring the post office into your home
your apartment or your cardboard box in
the sidewalk wherever you live in you
can bring the post office into your
dwelling all right they're gonna start
closing them soon you know you want to
be standing outside there like that poor
son of a [ __ ] who put all his money in
the bank and when the bank fails he's
standing out there with this little is
little little card with the number on it
but did you said it was in there you
don't wanna be that guy get the jump
post offices are closing the sky is
falling I'm using fear this week all
right go to stamps calm everybody what
the hell is it cut copy is attached I
thought I knew this one by heart now for
Christ's sake I know what it is you go
to stamps come this is the great thing
you're able to print legal stamps with
your own your home computer and your
printer whoever you need you just
bing-bang-boom you do it you can do it
whatever
or the day they give you a little scale
you know so if you want to go I don't
know it's Mother's Day coming up and you
bought something and you want to ship it
out to your mom you know you just put it
in a box put it on your scale you way it
bing-bang-boom get done put it out of
the mailbox a postman comes the next day
picks it up you don't even have to leave
your dang house all right if you act now
by listeners get a free $110 worth of
stamps and you just go to stamps calm
you click on the microphone with the
code B you are Arbor I'm telling you
this guy this is actually is now more
viable than ever considering they're
actually closing the post offices the
office is where they post and that's it
Gamefly gamefly.com is another one do
you know what else yesterday when I was
watching the NBA they out they did pro
flowers and the did gamefly.com and I
was thinking you know what the NBA
they're listening to my podcast they're
ripping me off they have the same
advertisers Gamefly so you keep it short
this week this is up to you if you want
to do this anymore or not what are you
talking about why would I want to keep
doing this I love gamefly.com you get
eight thousand video games at your
fingertips I guess that was an inside
note like I wasn't supposed to read that
gamefly.com everybody do you like video
games sure we all do how would you like
to have eight thousand video games at
your fingertips they can either be
delivered right to your gate right to
your house or you can download them
right on your own damn PC you get a 15
day free trial 15 days you can stay at
home use all your sick days your
vacation days played video games go-to
gamefly.com thank gamefly.com slash /
and you'll have access to all of those
there you go how is that those reads all
right hey remember the last few weeks
I've been telling you guys how I've been
trying to get into learning how [ __ ]
works and science and all that because I
have such a poor science background I
have a YouTube video of the week and it
basically it explains how a differential
works on your truck or your car
and it actually [ __ ] blew my mind now
the weird thing about this video is for
some reason the first like six minutes
of it you have to sit through policemen
on motorcycles doing all these different
formations and these X game tricks it's
from like the 1940s so it has that World
War 2 propaganda you know and you know
they're holding on to each other's arms
they're standing up riding around this
whole little [ __ ] Hitler Youth sort
of beginning thing it's really weird I
guess at one point when they're going
around they're trying to show the
principles of a car going around the
corner in the differential but it's
[ __ ] amazing and I know a lot of you
guys like Bill I don't give a [ __ ] I
don't want to learn how to fix my car
and you know when I say yes you do
the bekkie head there's no way when you
bring a car down to the dealership and
you know it's something simple but you
just never read up on it
there's no way you don't feel like a
[ __ ] when you're sitting there you know
I'm telling you I you know I didn't
realize about the differential I didn't
realize that it also allows I know it
took all the torque from the engine and
made it go 90 degrees but I didn't
realize it gave you back tires the
ability to turn independently that's
what blew my mind because it never
dawned on me that when you go around the
corner the inside tire has to go like
wait a waste shorter distance than the
outside tire so if they're both turning
at the same time one of them would be
sliding I don't know which one but so I
guess that makes sense
but for them to figure out a gear as to
how to get those things to turn
independently it's just it's [ __ ] it
just you just got to watch it alright
and if you watch it you're gonna be like
me and you're gonna get [ __ ] obsessed
with it and you're gonna buy the owners
manual to your [ __ ] car that is about
a thousand pages thick and you're gonna
finally like I've actually looking at
like explosion drawings of like
transmissions and my whole life I had no
idea what a [ __ ] transmission should
look like it's just boring the [ __ ] out
of all of you well can't I learn
something do I got to be the sports
talking [ __ ] for the rest of my [ __ ]
life hey how about those New York Knicks
everybody
those Knicks they finally won a playoff
game congratulations to all New York
Knicks fans unless you like the Yankees
then you can go [ __ ] yourselves ended a
30-day a 13 game in a row playoff game
losing streak I want to know what do you
guys think
when will that ever get beaten that's
gonna that one's gonna stand for a while
I was actually trying to do the math on
that in order to duplicate that
best-case scenario you only get swept
two years in a row
our two playoff trips in a row like best
case scenario would be you were up three
games to none one year and then you lost
four in a row so you didn't get swept
and there's four losses then you get
swept two more times in a row that's 12
and then you lose the first game in the
next one that's the best-case scenario
the [ __ ] Knicks lost some playoff
series when Van Gundy was still there
they lost to the last two games
so that was their first two loss then
they got swept that's six they got swept
again that's 10 then they lost the first
three of this one that's 13 I swear to
God if they lost yesterday that 14 you
would think yellow eight somebody could
beat that you'd have to get swept three
times in a [ __ ] ruts practically
impossible and this is what kills me is
Paul virzi old jersey virzi New Jersey
zone the pride of [ __ ] Red Bank he
[ __ ] we got this huge [ __ ] debate
he [ __ ] annoys the [ __ ] out of me
with his praise of Madison Square Garden
like he feels like like this venue like
that is the most overrated [ __ ] venue
I think in professional sports because
it gets so much [ __ ] clout because
it's in New York City the Paris of the
United States and just because it's
[ __ ] there that everybody seems to
forget
incredible lack of championships that
have been won there
okay the [ __ ] New York Rangers have
won one Stanley Cup since 1940 that's 72
[ __ ] years there's been one
championship won there the New York
Knicks haven't won since [ __ ] Nixon
resigned 40 [ __ ] years all right
and this dude is telling me you firs E's
always talking about how Jordan said
that was his favorite place to play and
he this other fight started he told me
that [ __ ] the garden during Game three
was the loudest NBA game he's ever heard
and I'm like really do you really think
that it was louder than the Boston
Garden or the LA forum when the Lakers
and Celtics were playing a game 7 do you
really think it was louder game 3 Knicks
versus the heat and you down [ __ ] Oh -
do you really think the venue was [ __ ]
louder I mean what do you basically goes
dude this isn't about Championships I'm
like it's not I'm not saying it's about
Championships but we were playing for
championship so you're gonna be even
amped up even more and he just keeps
saying how they use that stupid [ __ ]
expression that that that Madison Square
Garden eka it's a mecca for basketball
and it's what people don't understand I
don't do you understand what Mecca just
means people from around the world
gather there it's a gathering place it's
like if Madison Square Garden was in a
mall it would be a food court people
gathered from all over the mall some
people came there to buy a dress other
people came there to buy a slack buy
some slacks but they all gathered in the
food court to eat that shitty food and
yes it is a basketball Mecca people
gather from around the globe to kick the
Knicks [ __ ] ass every year if they
make the goddamn playoffs all right it's
just [ __ ] annoys the [ __ ] out of me
because I give it up to the Yankees for
him like like that that's that's the top
team in baseball it's not even close 27
championships right and he's gonna
[ __ ]
sit there and he's gonna try and talk
about Madison Square Garden like this is
the crown jewel of the [ __ ] NBA and
completely disregard the Celtics and
Lakers who combined have 132 NBA
championships putts the Lakers BB a
championship that they count as an NBA
championship for 33 and you're sitting
on [ __ ] - alright I can be honest
there's an outsider when I think of
Madison Square Garden I think of
Muhammad Ali I think of Led Zeppelin
Mach Messier occasionally I'll think of
Bernard King Frank Sinatra
Bruce spring you know Rolling Stones I
think more music
I don't think sports because nothing
really [ __ ] memorable what it what
has ever happen there I don't understand
what has happened at the broom is went
into the stands and somebody got beaten
with a loafer Mike Milbury right not to
rat him out but I mean it's on video
Mike I just don't understand like it
just I just tried to tell him I'm like
dude it's not louder it's not louder do
you think it was louder than when the
Celtics finally won another [ __ ]
championship after their drought of like
whatever what it was 22 years do you
really think it was louder than that I
was trying to explain to him it just
seems loud to you because you're a
Knicks fan you know it's like that dude
who was into the Asian women and he's go
out there do they play off the lazy yet
you just like Asian women it's the same
[ __ ] thing all right so just in case
there's some more Versys out there okay
you have a nice little venue down there
it stage was made during the cookie
cutter time some of the worst [ __ ]
venues ever the ceiling is ugly and
there's an unbelievable I've done this
joke before I always talk about the the
breeze and Madison Square Garden there's
an unbelievable breeze up on the rafters
because there's no championship banners
to block the air conditioning
so anyways having said that
congratulations to the Knicks if the
Knicks ever went on a run and were a
championship team even then the best
that they could hope to do is duplicate
what the Bulls did with Jordan when when
they were the center of the basketball
universe but in my lifetime they never
have been and I'm an old [ __ ] man I've
been around for a long time at this
point I'm halfway through this journey
if I'm lucky hopefully only halfway
through so there you go I went out of my
way to trash the [ __ ] Knicks even
though they just [ __ ] won I don't
know I don't even know [ __ ] about
[ __ ] uh I don't know [ __ ] about
basketball I just shut the hell up what
am i up to here 56 minutes alright let's
read some more advertising here all
right amazon.com everybody hey do you
like me do you like my podcast do you
all if you don't do you like the troops
I'm drafted behind you're like of the
troops this is the deal
next time you go to amazon.com not
saying yeah the next time you're gonna
buy something why don't you just go to
Bill burr com click on the podcast page
that thing opens up on the right-hand
side you're gonna see the amazon banner
you click on that thing and then just go
buy something if you want to and when
you do you'll be supporting my podcast
because I get a kickback and 10% of
whatever kickback I get from amazon.com
I throw to the Wounded Warriors Project
so you support my podcast and you
support the troops how about that can
you beat that I don't think you can so I
think that's it I think that is the the
podcast for this week wait there's some
overrated under Raiders remember those
things
underrated pissing in the shower one of
the most relaxing things you could ever
do gross just lean back hands-free and
just let go of all your worries trust me
sounds gross that's what he's but it's
awesome plus it all goes down the same
pipes and this way you'll save a flush
worth of water it's like the hybrid of
toilet time um it doesn't go down the
same
it doesn't go to the same pipe if you
[ __ ] jackass
it doesn't the toilet goes down your
[ __ ] sewage line alright they don't
all they don't all flush together tell
me they don't all flush together then
where does that water go to then get
treated and then I wash my hair with the
[ __ ] we y'all [ __ ] and piston probably
does this so many [ __ ] people does it
go down the same [ __ ] line no no it
what dude you would the smell of [ __ ]
would be coming right up your shower
drain maybe eventually it does I don't
think it does I thought they kept those
two separate Wow that's [ __ ]
disgusting can somebody please write me
and clear that up anyways frosting your
own beer glasses at home underrated
abso-fucking-lutely and by the way
you're required to do that okay if you
say hey you guys want to watch the game
at my place you are required to frost up
some glasses okay that's that's one of
the unwritten rule you know there's
unwritten rules you don't show up a
pitcher you don't I mean after the
whistle blows you don't shoot the puck
at the goalie those [ __ ] unwritten
rules you know the unwritten rule is
that you have your buddies over to watch
the game you got to frost up some
glasses you know and then get mad at
them when they pee all over the seat
overrated giant Oprah style mansions
with 20 bedrooms and [ __ ] I grew up
pretty poor and in some small houses and
I remember thinking as I was watching
those screen movies how that [ __ ] could
never happen to broke people they had
the rich kids in these giant ass houses
giant arse houses this guy must be from
Europe here and people getting murdered
in some other room while the rest of the
people were oblivious which made me
laugh as growing up I could hear my mom
in the kitchen walking around on the
wooden floor while I was in the bedroom
literally on the opposite side of
house no way some masked douche is
slaughtering someone d masking and then
walking back into the lounge like hey
guys what'd I miss so sleep tight there
Richie Rich that's [ __ ] hilarious but
you know what's crazy about those houses
is you know when you have like 20
bedrooms
you don't think about it but like those
rooms are useless 20 bedrooms so you got
to go out buy 20 beds what can you do in
your bed sleep and [ __ ] right do you
need to do then a bunch of other rooms
other than that how long does that take
for me sleeping and [ __ ] takes 8
hours and 7 minutes on a good day right
it's other than that it's just a useless
room I you need whatever three four
bedrooms and then after that everybody
can you know go sleep in the family room
go sleep in the movie room go sleep in
my study you want to turn those rooms
into something else I've never
understood I don't you don't want to get
yeah this is why I think those people
live in those kinds of some people just
want a giant house but there is got to
be something really comforting to live
in like the Illuminati's like cul-de-sac
you know like if I ever became like just
like some [ __ ] billionaire you know
which I really think is inevitable with
the wild success of this podcast and all
this advertising that pretty soon you
know I will become a billionaire
go [ __ ] yourself
whatever whatever say I invent the next
[ __ ] app for the iPhone and I make a
zillion dollars so you know there's got
to be something comforting when the
dollar is crashing if you're in this
giant gated [ __ ] community with its
own security ahh [ __ ] even then even
then cuz then you got to think the
security guy I would make friends with
the security people like ridiculous
friends I would like if I had that kind
of money I would pay off their houses
well then he wouldn't [ __ ] show up to
work I'd have to do something where they
were on my side you know I just make a
plan do when when the [ __ ] goes down
you can bring you and your family and
your pistol to my house all right I have
[ __ ] 10 years worth of beef in my
[ __ ] 4,000 square-foot [ __ ]
refrigerator freezer we can eat for 10
years all and I have enough bullets for
you to hold people off can can you do
this are you willing to do this or that
that's how I would play I would have my
own little mini militia you know I don't
buddy mine told me one time they were
haven't they had this fire in the
Hollywood Hills somewhere out here can
somebody please find me footage of this
because I refuse to believe that
somebody had this level of wealth but it
sounded awesome where the big thing
about if when you live in the hills out
here this is basically what happens all
right every year for like a month
straight it [ __ ] it seems like it
rains every day out here and during that
time all the hills turn all green and
they're beautiful and they're lush and
all that type of [ __ ] and then after
that occasionally it will [ __ ] rain
so what happens is gradually the hills
start to dry out and then towards the
end of the year the Santa Ana winds come
in off of the desert all right and it's
just flat so they come in and like
[ __ ] sometimes upwards of a hundred
miles an hour and it's like nature's
hair dryer and it just dries out all of
the hills and turns them this shitty
jesus is coming Brown and then
eventually something happens somebody
throws a cigarette out the window I
don't know what I don't know [ __ ]
rattlesnake takes a [ __ ] and hits a
piece of Flint I don't know how these
things work I have a bad science
background whatever the [ __ ] things
catch on fire and all these rich
[ __ ] that you're jealous of
during those months you're not jealous
of when you watch their [ __ ] houses
burned down so one time a buddy of mine
was saying he was watching the news and
somebody had so much [ __ ] money that
he the dude had his own fire department
basically and these guys were on top
with these [ __ ] fire retardant suits
and these giant like like cannons that
was shooting foam all over the perimeter
and all over the house so his house
didn't burn down and like the four
houses around him burned to the ground
and his house was fine just sitting in
this giant mountain of [ __ ] shaving
cream
and I just remember thinking that that
it that is that is the [ __ ]
like if I was wealthy that's what the
[ __ ] I would do you know I wouldn't help
the less fortunate I would make sure
that I could protect all my [ __ ]
wouldn't you yeah there was a nice
little selfish moment but I am I'm
selfish son of a [ __ ]
that's the podcast for this week hey
would you guys like to see me do
stand-up well why don't you go to bill
burr calm like I'm doing right now you
[ __ ] bastard where the hell is it
there we go these are some of my
upcoming shows I am gonna be in Lost
honglei's at a club called flappers I
swear to God it's called flappers it's
in Burbank I'm trying to build up my new
act and on may 25th I don't have the
date up on my website you don't have to
get it up there uh place called flappers
in Burbank California other things I
have coming up San Jose
I'm gonna be at the improv on the 15th
and the 16th unfortunately I had to
cancel the show on Sunday and on the
Sunday I'm gonna be at the Chicago
theater June 17th and then the Ontario
Ontario improv the 29th 30th and July
1st Jesus Christ his son where's the
stomach going
Hampton Beach ballroom casino in New
Hampshire Newport yachting center
Newport Rhode Island
I know that sounds fancy but it's a
giant tent outside in a parking lot so
don't don't be intimidated come on down
I need you to Caroline's on Broadway
July 26 through the 29th and uh who out
there is from Charlotte North Carolina
North cackling Lackey [ __ ]
I actually were in the process of
booking a date there on a weekend when
the Panthers have a home game so I'm
gonna go out to a game see Cam Newton
and uh by then my [ __ ] act ought to
be about three quarters ready my special
will be about a month away from coming
out so a bunch of dates yadda yadda
yadda please come out and see me once
again thanks to everybody's been
listening to the podcast making
donations
you know take it advantage of some of
the advertising that I bring in to you
you know anybody who orders the flowers
I really appreciate it
that is it that is all go [ __ ]
yourselves don't take any [ __ ] don't
hang out with lesbians thinking you're
gonna [ __ ] them either be friends with
them and trade ratchet sets or [ __ ]
move on alright that is it
god bless you and God bless the United
States of America
you